meow
Hi, guys, my name is Grace Helbig if you didn't know now you know your life is different now.
I'm in New York City!
Can you tell?
My voice is clearly hoarse because I have been participating in many a YouTube event while I've been
out here for the last couple of days.
And I thought I would make a stream-of-consciousness video for you guys today, because a lot of stuff
has happened over the last couple of days and I have yet to process all of it.
Here's just a few things that have happened to me over the last couple days:
WIll Smith talked in a room in which I was also in and he was great.
I got to interview the CEO of Beyonce's company, a guy named Steve Pamon,
who is absolutely incredible. And I...
How do you heal a brain that's melted?
When we were backstage before the interview talking and getting to know each other referred to
Jay-Z [as] Jay, and he referred to Beyonce as Bee.
He said something about Blue Ivy, so casually on the outside
I was like, "You know, I too have experienced that." but on the inside I was like
Saw Katy Perry perform live a giant room with a bunch of men in suits.
It clearly felt uncomfortable dancing also did not know what to do with our bodies
when music was being performed in front of them
so they just took their phones and
held it up and recorded the video just so they had something to do with their hands.
You're never gonna watch that video again, what are you doing?
I broke my phone screen. Wow, that's aggressive and concerning about the quality of life I live. Watch it.
Nope.
So, I'm doing just fine.
Did you know that there's been toilet paper sitting there this whole time?
And then I went to the musical 'Cats', and it was incredible-ly confusing.
I had absolutely no idea what was happening the entire show, and I was so okay with that
because confusion keeps you present.
What else has happened?
[ burps ] Oof, yeah.
Yikes! Ahh.
One part for the video and one part because my stuff smells like sh*t.
I parted my hair kind of down the center, and I don't feel the worst about it. That's exciting. Whoa content.
You get it.
Performance Art.
I'm America's Bjork.
I ordered enough sushi for a family of six, and then they gave me this "on the house," and it's fruit.
Oh, no, it went everywhere.
That was very expected. The difference between stupid and dumb:
Dumb is fun, stupid is...
Yeah, and I [wore] [men's] doctor since I was on a boat for a second it was minutes actually exciting to feel what the outdoors
Feels like every now and then turns out. It's cold, and I'm not bred for survival out there
Just me Flex don't the mystery bruises on my body. Which is always fun to know that the only thing
I'm consistent in is my inability to understand my own personal spatial awareness. That's [awesome]
That's it special set a me catch
Thanks me
When I landed in New York, I realize that I did not pack my computer charger or my phone charger
But I did pack these glasses, more than three pairs of headphones, and two chargers that are for devices
I don't even have with me
Lifestyle guru at your service.
Thank you cats
Everyone in Cats is insanely talented. Their voices are amazing
The dancing is out of control
I have never seen a broadway show with the caliber of dancing that Cats has nor have I ever seen a
Broadway show with the caliber of confusion that myself had you want to feel like you're hallucinating
without the like
emotional and physical
Exhaustion of taking hallucinogenics
CATS
There was definitely a scene that like insinuated all the cats like got in heat and like...we're doing some, you know,  passionate romantic
Animal things with each other and then it cut to intermission
And there was a cat on stage and all the kids in the audience go take a photo with so it's a complete
Unpredictable rollercoaster of emotion like have you ever been on a roller coaster where you're like?
Not sure they finished the tracks for the roller coaster, and it's completely in the dark
And you don't get to wear a seatbelt, but everyone's really cool and nice about it.
CATS
Okay, I'm gonna end this now! Thank you for watching this stream of consciousness
video. If you guys like these kind of videos give this video a thumbs up.
and don't forget to comment down below let me know
what's a live show that you've seen recently? I would love to know
and you don't forget to subscribe to this YouTube channel
I make videos Monday Wednesday and Friday sometimes oftentimes not but sometimes not a completely false statement
but also, not totally true
I don't know
CATS
Dietrich's much as I can also do trick shots?
So d search boxes I can also do a trick shots with props?
[15] Tricks trick shot